[Music]
all right so I have few slides for the
opening notes so we were the potato were
so conference 2017 the first conference
that was started as a meet-up two years
ago so a few pictures from the forms
first meet ups sorry I'm but stressed
about this reservation so my voice
shaking do it so yeah it was two years
ago we didn't even expect that so many
people in the first meetup but it was
about fifty eighty people then we had to
move to the other room like bigger one
and we have walked one hunt more than
100 people there on the meetup each time
right now and because of that because of
this authority of machine learning data
science all this stuff we for there's
gonna be nice to organize conference so
and this is it
so the conference we have two days for
keynotes forty two talks apart from the
keynotes ignite talks and after-party
today so I hope most of you will be
there this is our social channels so if
you want to tweet just please you the
tag you can join our slack channel for
the conference and further on I really
encourage you to join the ignite talks
we have a forum where you can subscribe
or again you can put your title over
there ignite talks are like five minute
short talks in front of the audience
where you can present your interesting
topic your project what we working on
so this we time for you on a stage after
party is today so I picked up her endo
starting from seven we have some snacks
we have free beer so feel welcome and I
want to show you at least the pictures
of the people that are standing behind
this conference so this is the
program committee Dominic got cash
starting from top row magic Mateos the
otter sweat and myself who's doing
excels so this this the this six seven
people has chosen all the talks and I
hope you like them and the whole
organization part was was taken by these
eight people so we have cloudy armed
with Mariana Sujata
Medina Marta Gosha Magda and and Philip
on the second row
these people are volunteers so they
working for the community and this is
what you see here is just the result of
their hard work for the past half year
so
in the future thank you for the plows
for them they were working downstairs so
I hope they've heard that so okay please
thank you so much for John we have a
pleasure to have guests from unfocus so
from the mother company mother brand
mother foundation that joined that
joined our tower even today so a few
words from Leah and James please welcome
to him here thank you so much we're so
excited to see everyone here I know
Rafal just mentioned that this has kind
of been two years in the making but I
remember the first call when Peter
reached out and said we're gonna we'd
like to have an event in Warsaw we
suggested to start with a meet-up and he
said oh I think we'll have an event will
be about 400 people and I was I thought
to myself well that's awfully aggressive
for a you know a first-time event
usually it's about 200 and and here we
are today so very impressed with with
their work on mobilizing the community
and bringing everyone together pie data
is an important program of num focus
we're here to support open source
scientific computing and more targeted
to the projects that we sponsor we have
22 projects under our umbrella right now
we're here to ensure or at least to
support and help ensure the
sustainability of the projects so that
is a lot of work on many different
levels and that is what we that's what
we do that's what our work is all about
we'd love you to come over to the table
I won't take a lot of time right now but
let us talk to you to you about some of
the specific programs and work that
we're doing to support the project so
that we all have them to continue to use
and whether that's on an industry level
or academic level we have stickers at
the table thank you so much
Leah and James gonna be for the whole
two days so you can find them I hope one
day after party and do any conference as
well so our partners without these
companies discover this this even
wouldn't wouldn't happen
so our Gold Partner Samsung called
partners Linkara code lime McKinsey and
company containing labs
Electrike so big thank you to you for
further support our community we have
also supporting partners fin dot AI in
at home and our community partners so
the companies that are giving some some
benefits we've already sent some emails
about for example three books one of the
most is written by Cameron high caffeine
sorry
and it's available to download so and
I'm done
please work on the stage our first
speaker Eric from Google hello thank you
me
[Applause]
you